[Music]
if you were in the market for a beach
home we've got the
top 10 list of places to purchase one
this year's locations from the west
coast to the east coast made the list
organized by rental return cap rate
factors in things like property taxes
utilities
hoa feeds insurance and property
management fees cape hatteras of north
carolina number one on the list followed
there by ocean shores on the coast of
washington
followed by a few different markets in
hawaii peppered in the complete list
there for you
vacasa says demand for second homes and
vacation destination
markets is very high right now and they
do expect that trend to continue
if you happen to be in the market for
one this is what you should keep in mind
the key important thing is to know the
local market
and then understand how you're going to
use the property is it a pure investment
uh in that case you want to find the
lowest price property with the highest
return
or is it something you and your family
are going to use and in that case you
have some personal needs like
how many bedrooms bathroom kind of the
floor plan vicasa has properties in more
than 400 markets